[Music]
well great to have you here as we were
chatting a little bit before the podcast
this one I think this is like two years
in the making we went back and forth and
then something I don't know is I'm sure
it's my fault
scheduling whatever but you're here I
saw you were in like Adelaide the other
day and when I emailed you to follow up
I was like wait are we still on what's
happening you're like yeah we'll be here
jet-lagged
yeah well I'm feeling alright we got we
always do this trick on the planes where
we get on dead last so that you know
what everyone's sitting and then you can
just choose all the seats that are free
and we both got three seats to ourselves
on the way so we've got - Leigh that's a
good that's a good little trick because
if this one empty it was every time and
every time no storage probably three
spots where your feet would usually go
so you make it work uh-huh well you've
been on this extended global tour for a
while now like do you even have a home
like you just seem to be completely
nomadic that's exactly how it is yeah
it's my fifth year now Wow almost my
almost five four years and it's been
I've been all over the place I haven't
been anywhere long even probably longer
than a month so it's been full-on man
living out of a bag and you know catch
hopping and seeing the world and also
yeah just rounding up activists and
saying what's happening in different
areas and yeah it's been a really really
awesome trip fresh wild man so you don't
pay rent anywhere no I don't man
occasionally but yeah for the most part
no we're just out of the bag and going
from A to B to C to D to e to F G a
human citizen of the planet yeah that's
why I say citizen of the earth yeah so
what what brought you to la la well I
wanted to do this podcast with you and
there's a couple of vigils we're doing
which is when we bear witness at the
slaughterhouses right I've got another
podcast to do with Laura Cleary and what
else is happening actually got no
speeches see but we're gone from here to
New York to do a few speeches of some
universities and also catch one or Tony
Robbins seminars oh cool yeah it's gonna
be fun
someone bought me a ticket and then I
actually
but one of his people messaged me and
said yeah if you need any help or hand
in anything let me know and I said well
actually my girlfriend would love to
come what I do about getting a ticket
and she said well actually you tell me
vegan so let me see what I can do and
she looked up caller you take it as well
that's pretty cool well I would imagine
that's been your experience for a while
now I mean you've really kind of existed
on the generosity you have a lot of
people that that support you and allow
you to you know spread the message and
do what you do
absolutely men its Bane yeah it's been
good to give and to receive as well I've
done all my speeches for free which is
hundreds of speeches now as I've
traveled I've never charged for my time
and I think a lot of people have
appreciated that and you know I wanted
to do that part and a lot of the time
it's just put me up and give me some
vegan meals keep me happy and man yeah
it's been you know such a great
community and there's so many people out
there who you know can't do what I'm
doing but what other activists are doing
and you know they're tied down for
whatever reason so it gives them an
opportunity to give back as well so
you've never charged for a speech I
think I've tried for one speech when I
was at a festival where I knew it was
pretty much all vegans and I was like
well if you guys are gonna make a bunch
of money from me doing this speech then
I might as well you know make a little
bit of money doing a speech too but I
mean a lot of those events are like that
they're charging admission they're
making money it's okay to have you know
some kind of honorarium to do that yeah
well I've done it once man and apart
from that yeah it's been all free man
especially you know when it's a when
it's an audience it hasn't really heard
the message I'm trying to share then I'm
more than happy to do it for free and
often I'll pay at my own pocket to get
there and things like that as well
that's cool so Tony Robbins that's gonna
be great over huge I had I had guru sing
in here recently and he just texted me
the other day from Dubai he was doing
some Tony Robbins event like Tony brings
him out
I don't know spread his spiritual oh
yeah love to everybody else which is
pretty cool so maybe the guru Singh will
be part of that too I hope so man so uh
let's break it down man you've got
you've got a crazy super interesting
story and path that brought you to this
place and I think what I think of you I
mean I first was introduced to you and
and the work that you do by way of the
ER silence which we're going to get into
I saw that piece on Australian morning
TV that kind of went crazy viral and
I've been following you ever since and
and when I think about not just what you
do but how you do what you do I see you
as this of course inspirational and also
very impactful advocate for this
lifestyle that we share but also as a
leader in this new generation of
activists and plant-based people who are
carrying the message in a different way
from their forebearers like you're doing
it in a very positive enthusiastic way
that that encourages participation and
it's aspirational and you you paint this
portrait of what this lifestyle is like
in a very optimistic engaging way that I
think is really effective in making
people excited about making the switch
and living this lifestyle when I look at
you I think of people like you know like
Simon Hill who we just talked about in
his plant proof podcast people like NEMA
Delgado like young people who are in
this for the right reasons and and are
really making an impact with people much
younger than me so super cool thanks man
I think that the people that came before
us they didn't have social media for
example and that is a really great way
of getting feedback so I wasn't always
doing it from this loving positive
compassionate place I was being more of
a hard-ass about it and a bit more
forceful about it and a bit more blame
and shame about it trying to get people
to adopt the vegan lifestyle because
that's what I'd seen happen in the past
and I had seen some success with that
with certain activists but what I found
through trial and error and feedback
through social media was that actually
being compassionate and encouraging and
educational and you know trying to get
people on board through the path of love
and reaching people's hearts
that was actually far more effective
yeah I find that and I'm interested in
your perspective on this I find that at
times the vegan movement has a tendency
to cannibalize itself oh yeah yeah I had
an experience the other day that that
really upset me where every year or the
last couple years I've used my birthday
to raise money for charity water to
build wells in communities throughout
Africa where these these villages have
never had access to clean water which of
course leads to all these diseases and
for $10,000 you can build a well that
will serve generations to come it's like
a super efficient way to have a huge
impact on a large number of people
awesome and I sent out an email blast
saying hey my 52nd birthday I'm trying
to raise this much money
consider a contribution and I got a
really snarky response back from some
good person who shamed me and told me
that you know why am i supporting these
people that don't care about the animals
and are just you know using all this
plastic and like you know trying to make
me feel bad like I'm putting I'm placing
my efforts in my advocacy in the wrong
place and I thought this is why people
can't find vegans unpalatable well why
are you leaning on somebody who's trying
to do something pop happens all the time
and two things happen I've noticed when
you go vegan one is that you lose all
your social skills it's like you forget
how to talk to people you know and
people would just come with this anger
and frustration and it's understandable
but it definitely doesn't get you very
far in fact it can just push people
further in the wrong direction
and the second thing that happens is
that people forget that they were ever
not vegan so as soon as the day comes
when somebody decides to go vegan then
it's like they always have been and
everyone who's not is a monster and yeah
it's just this weird thing that happens
but I think what happens is that when
when you make the connection as we say
in the community when you make the
connection which is that if there's no
need to kill any animals to survive
which is what we learn that there's not
and we can get every essential nutrient
we need through a plant-based
then it's so blatantly obvious that all
the violence we inflicts mercilessly in
such a brutal way to billions of
sentient beings every day it's so
glaringly obvious that it's wrong but
the day before that happened the day
before you realize that it was just
totally normal
you thought it was natural necessary and
so yeah it's actually a really big
switch that flicks when people get it
and so that's why there's all this
frustration but that's one part of it
the other part of it is just what you
were talking about that everyone's
thinks that there's only one way up the
mountain and it's my way or no way and
yeah it's a big problem actually but I
think the best thing to do is just know
that if you're if you're getting the
feedback that you want which is that
people are being inspired by your work
and making changes then forget about all
those other people who are saying all
that crap because you know that you're
being effective and you just got to keep
moving forward and rise above all them
yeah I would I would cash out by saying
that all voices are important and I
think that that super hardcore
perspective serves a purpose which is it
reminds us where that line is and as
much as it was upsetting to get that
email from that person I have compassion
for that person sensitivity and their
point of view and it works as a reminder
to tell me like hey you know this is
important and let me be more mindful of
the choices that I make I think
ultimately the the manner in which you
communicate is more effective in terms
of really penetrating the hearts and
minds of people but I think that super
hardcore perspective sets the tone you
know I think so it's like you can have
Gary Franchione who has like a zero
tolerance policy anyone yeah okay well
that that there's the line like he's
telling us this is where the line is
yeah and we all have to find our own way
of communicating in a way that feels
right for us and I think every voice
finds its audience in a certain way and
it's all good it is all good man exactly
spreading the message you're going to
reach people and I'll reach people that
Franchione dozen and Hillary
people that I don't but as long as we're
all doing our part then the weight of
this enormous atrocity is shared between
us all and that makes it a little easier
to keep going right well let's track it
because you came into this from a very
interesting experience that you had so
you grew up tell me about what it was
like growing up Australia it was cool
yeah it was good I did a lot of
skateboarding and I did a lot of karate
I got my black belt in karate when I was
quite young oh wow yeah and then I can
see the skateboarding thing yeah yeah
I've been getting myself into much later
actually but now I'm actually really a
huge fan of surfing we're in Australia
Sydney South Sydney yeah place called
Engadine and yeah just a just a pretty
typical you know childhood man for
someone living in the burbs kind of
thing and when I was 17 I was diagnosed
with leukemia and lymphoma given six
weeks to live unless I started treatment
immediately and I felt totally fine I
was in the hospital room doing chin-ups
like you guys sure about this I feel
really good I just had some lumps like a
lump under my neck that turned into
about thirteen golf-ball-sized lumps Wow
also under my arms in my groin and turns
out that pretty much all of my lymph and
I was like a couple hundred of them were
inflamed in my body that's seventeen
yeah yeah so non-hodgkins or what kind
of lymphoma
it was t-cell lymphoma acute
lymphoblastic leukemia and tastes only
fight my supposed to be rude deadly they
gave me yeah really six weeks to live
six weeks to live and a pretty small
percentage chance of actually getting
through all the chemo because they
really dosed me up man so I you know I
was fine for a little while I had some
bad reactions to some of the meds I will
give him me by about a month in I was
starting to you know feel the brunt of
it I hadn't barely moved in a month I
was stuck in my hospital room everyone
was just coming and visiting me like
well I can't believe this is happening
and I kind of just my first reaction was
now this isn't the end man you'll be
fine and I think just having a default
positive about it she probably went a
long way I was young I was kind of
probably naive as well mm-hmm
but yeah I ended up suffering a lot I
some really painful reactions to some of
the chemotherapy drugs which felt like
you know I woke up one morning I went to
bed fine I woke up next day felt like
I'd been beaten with a baseball bat on
my legs every 30 seconds or so it was
like a knife was being dragged up my
spine and took about six shots and
morphine before I was feeling any relief
so I was really hurting man I put on
about thirty five kilos now so it was
about 25 kilos you know about what a
very short amount of time so fast that I
have stretch marks that appeared and
they actually ripped my skin ripping a
bled with this fourth is that just from
inflammation because it's not usually
people become you know they lose a lot
of weight on chemotherapy they put me on
a huge dose of steroids and all I wanted
to do was eat I couldn't stop eating and
that actually triggered a lot of other
problems that came further down the line
but basically I was not sleeping about
22 hours a day I was awake and I was
trying to eat as much of that as I could
because I had this insatiable appetite
which considering and now probably also
was just an emotional eating thing and
that's where I think that started for me
I had nothing else to do man I was stuck
in my hospital rooms as before a lot of
cool technology you know so so
everything that like just in traditional
protocol for treating totally has no
idea there are other options men so I
went straight in like that and and also
it was so well I had six months
intensive and then I had another two and
a half years of once a week maintenance
Wow which still slee me around every
week I probably didn't help that I was
doing a ton of drugs throughout that as
well
the maintenance stuff but I just thought
you know I could die any day so I just
want to enjoy myself I was 17 I wanted
to party and yeah so basically I had six
months intensive in that time I put on a
lot of weight I just my whole how I
looked totally change I had a rash over
my whole body my hair had fallen and I
had all this weight I looked like a
ghost and yeah some scars I had tubes
coming out of me you know the central
line that was in my chest got infected
with pneumonia so for a few days there I
you know I was almost I was pretty much
on death's door there they said if I'd
have stopped it one more traffic light I
probably would have died I really
couldn't breathe and
time was behind the weight of the
hospital for the first time you mean
well you know like for the next days as
well in hospitals just hooked up to this
to the oxygen and just every breath was
a struggle and if I lost my rhythm with
a little bit of a cough or something
then I was freaking out man and they
didn't want to take me to ICU because
just even that trip down was a risky
move so yeah it was nightly it was an
alley experience of suffering and I'm
really glad I had it actually you know I
took a while to recover but I fully
recovered and I'm at a point now where I
think that really helped me appreciate
what suffering is even though
comparatively to so many humans and
non-humans as well it's it's a you know
just a taste of it really I'm actually
very lucky but you know before that I
really hadn't suffered it at all and I
think that's an experience that a lot of
us can relate to that we we don't suffer
that much you know we sprained an ankle
or maybe we we hurt ourselves this way
or that way and some of it was obviously
worse than others but I think a lot of
people really miss attic miss out on
that experience of truly you know
fearing for your life and suffering
well pain can be quite the teacher
absolution let in the right direction
we live our lives in a culture that
teaches us to avoid that at all costs
and that we should seek luxury and
convenience and all the modern you know
amenities of what it means to live in
the developed world and the truth is at
least for me my personal experience is
that I feel most alive when I place
myself in difficult situations that
cause some level of self induced pain or
suffering you know you know all about it
and I think you know there's that saying
that growth only happens when you step
outside of your comfort zone mm-hmm
whether you step outside or whether
you're forced outside but you're
guaranteed to grow if you stay out there
long enough and you start becoming
comfortable with what was once
uncomfortable and that's where the
growth happens yeah that's why you hear
in recovery addicts and alcoholics who
say that there are grateful alcoholic or
grateful addict because it has taught
them so much and provided them
with a new toolbox and roadmap for how
to live that they perhaps would have
never stumbled upon or discovered had
they not suffered from this condition
absolutely yeah there's always good to
funding the bad you know and that's
that's the practice yeah so the survival
rate for this pretty low right it was
low yeah I think maybe it's probably be
better now that was a while ago now that
was maybe 14 years ago and cancer-free
ever since yeah no drama Center you
still have to go in and make sure is
there a chance that it comes supposed to
I listen to confident at my health these
days huh yeah so no I I don't go there
anymore it's been a while now you know a
lot of Kansas I say in 10 years if you
if you haven't relapsed and you're cured
with mine they just said every year that
you don't there's less chance that you
will yeah but personally I feel like you
know I feel like yeah maybe maybe I
created my own cancer with some negative
thought patterns from my childhood and
you know after dealing with that that's
why I kind of believe that it won't come
back man so and it might be totally to
see my head but that's just something I
have a feeling about yeah people get
people get defensive when you start
talking about cancer in those terms yeah
I have noticed that myself yeah and you
know it's speculation and that could
have been a lot of other factors and
there probably was but I think that you
know your your headspace your mind frame
matters so much and our thoughts create
some of the experiences we have and if
you have really negative thoughts that
that's creating you know the stress
hormones in your body and other probably
toxins and things like that that are
gonna affect you negatively and if it's
really bad I don't think it's far
fetched to say that potentially that
kind of negative thinking can affect
your body in a way that can let cancer
cells start to duplicate yeah of course
I mean we like to think that our brain
exists separate from our body but of
course that's not the case and if
there's anything that I've learned over
the course of hosting this podcast it is
these things are one in the same and if
we're not treating the mind in the way
that we're treating the body we're
missing an opportunity to be healthy in
the most holistic sense these two things
inform each other they influence each
other and I think if somebody was to say
that your mindset has no impact on
whether your body is susceptible to
disease on in in whatever form I think
that that is myopic at best absolutely
yeah okay but you seemed like you were a
positive kid right and you weren't you
weren't born and bred vegan like you're
you're live from Sydney suburban active
skater Karate Kid lifestyle are you
eating at that time growing as much meat
as I could every meal every I wake up in
the mornings and have steak for
breakfast my favorite meal was ribs or
lamb chops and basically I didn't think
that a meal was a meal unless there was
meat on it so I was I was one of the
biggest meters out of everyone I knew I
was turning vegetarians back on to meat
as a personal trainer and my personal
training career which I did for eight
years and I just didn't think it was
possible to be healthy without it so
also I thought why would you live
without it
animals don't matter and I never I never
understood animals I didn't like animals
I had a couple of dogs growing up I
didn't spend barely any time with them I
just really didn't like them and I know
not like them but just didn't see any
value in them I was very much under the
impression that they they were nothing
like us other animals were nothing like
humans and that you know they were
barely worth considering because I
thought that they couldn't care about
their own lives they didn't have that
capacity so why would I care about their
lives it didn't it wasn't logical in my
mind I was just extremely misinformed
about who we're sharing this planet with
well walk me through that shift in your
perspective and light sir okay well that
was the way it was until I was about 26
uh-huh and so you become 17 you're sick
you're like 20 you're on the mend
well I yeah something like that I was on
the mend before I was 20 like bat pull
you know
or so when I was starting to feel like
okay I'm coming out of this now in that
time I'd become a personal trainer I did
my course at college and started working
in a gym while I was still in chemo but
I think that was kind of inspirational
for my clients at the time you know even
I wasn't the perfect picture of health I
was working on that and yeah for the
next seven or so years I was a personal
trainer I was also partying heaps and I
also got a really pretty bad I mean I
don't know comparatively I guess I
haven't spoke to that many people with a
similar problem but I got I was really
battling with their eating disorder with
bulimia and I think like I mentioned a
minute ago that started from my
emotional eating in hospital and I
didn't understand that I was emotional
eater so I was you know there was there
was no way to satisfy the craving I had
because the craving I had wasn't for
more food it was because I just didn't
know how to sit with this uncomfortable
thing the craving is spiritual totally
exactly I mean it's something that I've
walked through and experienced and and I
think it's important to talk about
because I think that there's a lot of
guys out there who fall on that spectrum
of emotional eating whether it's you
know periodic or whether it becomes
full-blown anorexia or bulimia I think
there's a lot of guys out there that
suffer silently and we don't talk enough
about how this impacts dudes they're in
now in this Instagram culture you know
in the fitness space I would have to
imagine that that the rates of this have
been are escalating yeah I think you're
probably right I think for me it was a
little different than maybe you know it
wasn't a body thing necessarily for me
it was truly I was eating eating my way
to feel good mm-hmm
not so much I need to lose weight a cow
eat all this food and then I'll I'm
gonna back up it was in Rhett sorry to
interrupt but in retrospect now with
some perspective what do you think the
the wound was that you were treating it
was it was a addiction to binge 80
and then so I was I would be in a tight
eating EDD trying to feel good from
eating more of the food that made me
feel good like ice cream and chocolate
and things like that so I'd eat these
foods that would give you that that
higher kind of thing but as soon as
you'd take your last mouthful the high
would start to fade so you just keep
eating keep eating and then one time I
did that to the point where I felt so
sick and I thought I can't keep this
down I need to just spew this up and I
did do that and I felt better and I
thought oh I found the hack uh-huh and
so that's what I started doing I'd binge
until I needed to screw and I would
vomit and then I would binge again and
it was horrible man I've never felt so
out of control in my life it was the
hardest battle I've had and I've had a
few and I was really you know I was
really struggling this for a long time I
thought there was no way out I didn't
know what to do I was sometimes binging
and purging you know half a dozen or
maybe even of more times a day and just
wow yeah and I said no idea how to get
out of it man and I was a personal
trainer at the time trying to teach me
how to be eight healthy and bein well
and I felt like I had answers but then I
looked at myself in the mirror I thought
you mustn't have the answers so I felt
like such an impostor right and it was
it was hard to deal with men and there
that creates a lot of shame so I'm gonna
closes you off from everybody and I'm
I'm eating this food like binging
thinking man this kids starving to death
and I'm I'm doing this to food like what
are you doing but I didn't understand
that it was emotional and so what were
the emotions that you were treating like
that's what I want to get out what was
the source of this it was it was really
just a lack of ever really looking
inside you know going inside myself and
observing and just I just didn't want to
feel uncomfortable I was sick of feeling
uncomfortable I had been doing a lot of
drugs for many years I was always
chasing the hyo's always chasing the
feel-good and so I guess what happened
was I am you know I went on this cruise
ship to work after to be a personal
trainer so I've been doing that for
seven years or so I get on this cruise
ship and for that year I didn't do any
drugs which was the first year that I
hadn't done any I'd mix it around I'm
not gonna do exercise
I'm just gonna do mushrooms we're gonna
do mushrooms am I'm gonna do acid and I
mixed it up with good right I'm coming
out of this you know sweeten it around
just you know you know try that yeah
yeah it works okay no I wasn't it wasn't
exactly the top that was more of the
path of the circle I notice it going
around you know I have to do that to
realize how out of control it is totally
and you know like I definitely you know
that was a time when it was really bad
like I ended up in I got locked up in a
padded cell and a few days later a psych
ward and I had drug-induced psychosis
for about six months
it was gnarly really really I mean man
some stories out of that is just crazy
but when I came out of all that you know
the drug use had got a lot better I
stopped smoking weed and I limited it
quite a bit comparatively to how I'm
bein when I get on this cruise ship so
the week before I go to the cruise ship
I did a week worth of mushrooms in
barley because I heard that they don't
show up in your drug test they just show
up as food poisoning so that's a good
that's a good way to get around I'll get
a bunch in for a week and then I'll go
to the training in London to get on this
cruise ship they drug test you their
wine show up and then I'll have a year
off and that'll be cool because I really
wanted this job I thought it was a dream
job travel around the world for free and
you know just get people healthy and
teach them about that right work on this
cruise ship so I get on the cruise ship
I spend that whole time getting better
and better at the job that I had kind of
plateaued in for a while I feel I was
doing a lot of seminars which was really
out of my comfort zone I was such a bad
public speaker growing up and it was my
biggest fear so I really came out of
that fear although it took a little
while and that was really pushing it and
then I also was learning a lot from
other people with different ideas then I
had about health I was meeting one or
two thousand new people you know he'll
come on that ship and a bunch of them
coming in to the gym every week so I was
really challenging my views on what
healthy was and then I met this man who
actually was not the future of health at
all but he'd been a vegetarian for 20
years and I was like man you need to
start eating meat ASAP you are going to
die real like any day now I'm telling
you
the deficiencies must be out of this
world but he was like I mean during this
20 years you know you know you do not
need to eat meat to be healthy and there
was a very interesting guy as an Indian
guy really wise really spiritual and I
was totally feeling you know this guy's
vibe so I thought man maybe I'll try it
like he'd he'd bestowed a lot of
knowledge on me over the two weeks of
his cruise and gave me a lot of his time
and you know I just I don't know I just
so maybe I'll just try and hopefully
I'll just be out across it off my list
and be like yeah that's not for me going
vegetarian is definitely not for me I
don't want to do that I never want to
try it again and I kind of just hoped
and expected that's what would happen
and actually within days I noticed
improvements in how I felt after meals
and my energy was great and I was really
wanting to Train and push it out in the
gym and this is all shocking to me
so this guy's like you're Eskimo that's
what they say in recovery like the
person that brings you into recovery so
they asked him out and that's
interesting like I'm sure you had met
vegetarians before in your life
I have something about this dude that
that connected with you in a different
way like what do you think it was about
the way that he communicated with you
that that allowed that message to
penetrate in a way that that previously
it didn't well I've been in in all the
years as a personal trainer I was always
very interested in self-development and
you know reading books that would help
me connect more spiritually be a better
person a more positive person and you
know just shine brighter and he put it
he didn't talk much about the industry
or even talk about all about as far as I
remember all he said was eating animals
is bad karma and that's what resonated I
was like damn I don't want bad karma I'm
trying to do all these things to get
good karma like I'm not perfect or
anything but I am trying to help people
and I am very passionate about that
that's why I'm a personal trainer wasn't
just for the money was very much because
I wanted to help people out of their
suffering because I knew how bad it was
and that's what he said eating animals
is bad karma I said there's no such
thing as a healthy vegetarian said I've
been vegetarian 20 years I said damn or
I'm gonna look into this I tried it for
a week I felt better and I started
reading more about it I read a big book
on it called healing with Whole Foods
just coincidentally that had fallen in
my lap and it wasn't a vegan book a
plant-based diet book it was kind of
like Chinese medicine kind of thing I
gave you haven't heard of that book
really cool it's got a lot of recipes in
the back it's all Whole Foods and but
basically it goes through all these
conditions and the answers all these
conditions is to eat a plant-based diet
eat a plant-based diet and I was like
I'm noticing a trend here maybe I should
look more into this and I've always been
so closed off to it you know as a
personal trainer things had come in my
in you know in front of me that I did
notice oh this is saying that meat is
bad so I just brushed it out of my way
well I don't want to bother reading that
I'm never ever gonna stop eating meat me
stop eating meat how am I gonna what am
I gonna do I cannot gonna enjoy my meal
it's not worth it I don't care about
health of that much and I'm gonna stop
eating meat and I've seen other things
about you know like worms coming out of
you know parasites coming out of pork
when coca-cola was poorer and just
different things that kind of grossed me
out but knowing you and if I just saw oh
where's that guy getting his pork man
ain't getting it from my supermarket
my mind doesn't do that so that had all
been in my you know coming in my path
but I just totally discounted it now I'm
never gonna do it and if I learn about
it and I tell my clients about it but I
don't follow it I'm gonna look like a
hypocrite so what's the point
mm-hmm and you know I started getting
interested because of this book I was
reading and what he'd said to me so I
start looking into it more online and
with an open mind for the first time
because I tried it for a little while
and trying it for a little while made me
realize oh this foods actually good well
I can't get full doing this I still am
pushing it out in the gym okay so I
realized it was possible that's what
opened my mind and also I don't know if
this is related but I feel like it
probably is there is a quote a Buddhist
quote that is the consumption of animal
products extinguishes the seed of great
compassion so I feel like I was eating
all these animal products I just wasn't
feeling
in any way to change and the first thing
I learned was that not only can you be
healthy on a plant-based diet but you're
likely to live longer and reduce your
chances of developing most of the worst
diseases and most popular diseases that
our societies currently face with like
heart disease in number one killer and
the plant-based diets that only diet
proven to reverse it in the majority of
patients and dropping cancer rates by
huge numbers and all these things that I
thought how did I miss this massive
thing and how did my personal training
mentors that I had for a while and my
personal training manager and all the
guys I worked around and at a fat
college how did I never hear this side
of the story that this is healthier and
I think everyone was probably just as
closed off toward as I was because
eating meat is so normal and such a part
of our culture and you know it's it's
it's all of it it's that meat is manly
in that we need meat for protein and
dairy for calcium and all of these lies
that we have been duped into believing
yeah we've come a long way in just the
last couple years alone I think in in
debunking a lot of those myths but
there's so much energy and money and
momentum behind all of those stories
that simply attempting to rebut them let
alone overcome them requires a
tremendous amount of persistence in
order to do so and I feel like we're
where were inching up towards a turning
point with all of this and a lot in
large part due to alternative forms of
media mmm because as you know as
somebody who does a lot of interviews
there's a lot of mainstream outlets that
really don't want to talk about this
because their advertising base comes
from the pharmaceutical industry and the
animal agriculture industry and the
processed food industry and they're not
so keen on this message getting out to
the public because it of course
undercuts the revenues and and
contradicts the advertisements that come
30 seconds after
the talking point right and I think it
is you know I had a similar experience
in which a similar experience that was
revelatory for me you know that's not
that distinct from from your own story
in which my own direct experience of
trying this diet and expecting it not to
work but being open-minded enough enough
to explore it created results that I
would have not foreseen or expected and
I think I kind of went into it not from
an ethics point of view but purely from
a selfish health perspective and I think
a lot of people have you know everybody
has their different entry points but I
think there's a lot of well-meaning
people that get interested from the
ethics perspective who decide that
they're going to be comfortable with
this bargain that ok I'm gonna I'm gonna
cut all the meat and dairy products out
of my diet and if I'm gonna if that
means that I'm gonna lift a little bit
less in the gym or run a little bit
slower like I'm ok with that
totally and what is amazing and what I
gather was your experience and certainly
was mine was that it was exactly the
opposite my gains became they were like
exponentially more than they were prior
to that absolute was like I look at it
like it checks every box man all the
books you know every box is better for
the planet it's better for your health
it's better for your performance and
it's certainly better for the animals oh
good and when you when you kind of go
down the line and look at it from that
perspective it I have a greater empathy
for those people that are frustrated
with the fact that there is so much
resistance to these ideas totally you
can't you can't blame anybody because
yeah it is it's in my opinion it's just
a form of brainwashing all these all
these propaganda they put out there like
for example last night we were at a
slaughterhouse as the trucks came in
stopping the trucks taking photos taking
footage and the walls of the
slaughterhouse were covered in a mural a
big painting of these farmers lying down
reading books to
pigs and a little girl giving a flower
to a pig and this is on the
slaughterhouse walls so it's painting
this picture of yeah we're so kind to
our pigs meanwhile they get forced
inside there they get shot in the head
with a ball gun and then they get
stabbed in the throat and they they
suffer and scream and feel all the same
kind of pain that you that we would feel
if you were stabbed in the throat and
shot in the head and yet that's the
picture they paint so I think there's so
much to this this industry and this
enterprise and the propaganda and people
just go along with it of course of
course I kill them by making okay yeah
yeah yeah and and it's it's man up in
all over the world like we were talking
about earlier even kids
the first question but where to get
protein all over the world you know even
in even in India and Scotland and
Australia and here and Norway just
everywhere man is fed with the same
story the same narrative which is Wow
great job to them they've done an
amazing job of duping us all into
thinking we need this carcinogenic
protein and it's magical it only is
found in meat so many people believe
that health professionals believe that
doctors believe that and it could be
further from the truth what we need for
better health is to get protein from
plant which it is found in abundance
yeah it's a really interesting you know
that that's a really interesting side of
it I think all of the corruption and all
of the the propaganda that people
believe now I think that's a whole focus
on time with somebody who's probably
knows a bit more about it yeah I mean
listen you know animal agriculture is
one of one of our leading industries and
we have a situation in which the
government it's unclear where
governments and lobbying efforts and
regulatory bodies and and consumer
interest begins because the the FDA is
really just a quasi government
organization that is
funded I think either the might in the
dairy industry you go into public
schools and there's posters saying milk
does a body good yep like who gets to
advertise in a public school I mean it's
insane when you actually think about it
but when you just grow up with that I
don't know what it's like in Australia
but in the United States there's milk
posters in the public schools other
industries don't get to advertise to
young kids in that way why do they get
that permission because of this quasi
you know sort of pseudo government
entity that's really a private interest
lobbying effort to get people hooked on
these products as early on as possible
and that's where the minds are malleable
enough to submit these stories in their
minds I create habits that serve people
for the rest of their lifetimes
absolutely and that's what you see in
this process a when I'm doing outreach
with people and asking questions after
my speeches is that people have never
really thought these answers through you
know after they say all you need me for
protein I say well do you think that
protein is found in any other foods and
you can see that's kind of the first
time they've ever considered oh yeah
protein I guess is found in other foods
and you know you ask the questions will
if you can find protein other foods
other Emme nutrients you think that are
only found in meat that you can't find
in plants and a lot of people they don't
have answers to these questions they've
never gone the next step but actually
question any of these things we've we
were taught in school as kids it's just
the norm the hilarious irony is that and
you mentioned it earlier if somebody's
going to forgo meat and dairy the
immediate next question is well you're
gonna be deficient right so exactly if
you if you swap off swap the meat and
dairy off your plate and then you
suddenly adopt a bounty of different
kinds of plant foods close to their
natural state you're actually going to
increase your ingestion of all kinds of
phytonutrients and micronutrients and
minerals and vitamins because you're
diversifying your plate in a way that
that far exceeds what you're getting
when you're eating cheeseburgers and
fries and pizza or whatever else you
know
most people typically eat so it's just
bizarre I I would have said the same
thing but when you actually take a
moment and go all right well let's
really think this through the question
makes no sense absolutely and you know
what you said was so true your your
first question on my first question I
think a lot of people at least who are
interested in fitness is am I going to
lose my gains am I going to perform less
that was my first question so I got that
you know that roadblock handled
straightaway when I learned that some of
the most elite athletes on the planet
cleaned the world record holding
strongman consuming absolutely no animal
products so that was done but for me a
big question after that was am I going
to ever enjoy a meal again if I'm
cutting animal products out of it am I
going to be able to you know have foods
that I enjoy and I was really grateful
to find that not only is there an
abundance of like literally millions at
our disposal with a few clicks on our
phone of recipes plant-based recipes
made from whole foods that taste
absolutely delicious but we also in 2018
replicate meat dairy products eggs
everything that you can think of that
you once needed an animal for we now
have foods that taste the same that
smell the same that look the same that
are generally healthier and no animals
were killed and you don't miss out on
anything except for cholesterol which is
a good thing yeah the food industry has
finally figured out how to make these
things taste good and and they're doing
it with less and less you know processed
ingredients you know for a long time we
kind of had to tolerate these you know
sausage patties or whatever that tasted
terrible but now there's plenty of
options they all taste good and in this
moment that we're experiencing of
content penetration on the internet
there are a bazillion YouTube videos
that will walk you through whatever
question or conundrum or recipe that
you're looking for so when people say
well I don't live in your Whole Foods or
I don't you know whatever those answers
are readily available to those who are
inclined to search them out absolutely
and I think what I searched at before
that was more reason why and that's when
you know I'd done that wake as a
vegetarian I've learned that you can be
healthy I got excited
started trying to preach that to my
clients hey I know I told you to and
last week I was eatin steak and telling
you that now I'm telling you you know
chickpeas instead but I also wanted to
find out you know I open my mind to
ethical side of it and I thought okay
I'm gonna watch this documentary
Earthlings which shows all the ways that
humans exploiting kill animals for food
clothing entertainment medical testing
and I've seen slaughterhouse footage
before my brother showed it to me and he
said you never eat meat again if you
watch this and I watched it and I did
not feel a trace of sadness I said mate
we are human we have to eat animals to
survive if you want to feel guilty about
it that's up to you but I'm not going to
that's just how it is men and I didn't
any film nothing
and then when I watched Earthlings with
a new understanding that we can live and
thrive on a plant-based diet I was
actually so appalled and although I was
not an animal lover
I know suffering when I see it and
there's a difference between okay but we
have to do this to survive and oh we're
just creating all this suffering and
violence and killing of these emotional
intelligent feeling beings who are just
like us you know we're animals humans
animals they're animals in the ways that
matter we are the same they just look a
bit different on the outside and when I
saw or doing to them I just thought okay
I am so out this is not in alignment
with the kind of person I'm striving to
be which is a peaceful person a
respectful person a compassionate person
every time I purchase an animal products
even though I'm not doing the killing
myself I'm paying someone else to do the
killing and that makes me equally
responsible
I would never stab an animal to death
just because I like how their body
tastes if I was stranded on a desert
island maybe I would because you got to
do what you got to do to survive but
just because I like I like how their
body tastes and I feel like an extra
flavor on my sandwich no way no way and
I think yeah when most people consider
that themselves could you kill yourself
if you if you didn't have to and you
just felt like that when there's other
foods available would you do that
killing most people wouldn't and that
that alone is telling a lot most people
compassionate people who have just been
taught to do to contribute to an
extremely bad thing I mean in our
society throat-slitting is no joke you
know if if you know someone who slits
throats every day and eats their murder
victims
you're gonna stay well away from them we
have a big problem with serious violence
any violence but especially something
that intense and yet every single day
we're paying people to slit throats for
us and stab animals to death and and why
we're okay with that is because we
discriminate against them so strongly to
the point where our enjoyment of a
flavor for five minutes is more valuable
in our eyes than their life or ending
their suffering but God said that we are
here to have dominion over the animals I
wish you didn't say that that I read a
book called eternal Treblinka which
highlights the parallels between the
Nazi Holocaust and you know the
Holocaust they created and also the
animal Holocaust which is what it is a
mass slaughter of innocent beings and
it's said in that book that the worst
thing that ever happened to animals was
that quote in the Bible and I think that
that Bible has been translated many
times I think more likely a
compassionate loving merciful God Jesus
the Prince of Peace the Lamb of God
would not be okay with stabbing sentient
beings to death when as another option
and I think that we should embody the
good teachings of Christ if that's
something you want to believe in which
was of being loving being compassionate
helping those in need there's no one
more in need or there's equal to but
there's not that many individuals right
now lined up systematically waiting for
their execution bred into existence for
the purpose of being executed so so
human and it can feast on their corpses
I think Jesus would be very much against
it and I think it's in the commandments
the
shalt not kill chapter 1 it says that
God gives us every every fruit and every
seed-bearing plant as food that's our
food well even if or assuming presuming
that that that passage in the Bible has
been translated you know however many
times from its original text and intent
which there can be plenty of discussions
about doesn't does it not just boil down
to how we define the term Dominion that
is that being inferred to mean that that
that we can do as we please without
repercussions or does it mean that that
that level of control that we have the
ability to exercise comes with a certain
responsibility absolutely men absolutely
and and we're so great at that in so
many other areas we create so many laws
that protect each other humans are
protected and violent people go to jail
or sometimes worse in this country they
get executed from you know in different
states right that's a that's protection
and we're greater using our
responsibility and duty of care with the
power we have to put good practices in
place to protect the innocent and the
vulnerable yet we throw that all out the
window when it comes to pigs cows
chickens and fish and it's called
speciesism I'm sure you know all about
it we're just like why people
discriminated against black people
because they're a different race
thinking that that was a worthwhile
reason to enslave others they look
different they're not like us you know
and and the Wow
I mean to think that they could have
done that based on something so
ridiculous as the color of your skin or
how you looked and men did the same with
women and humans do the same with other
species of animals you know we love dogs
we love dolphins we love whales but we
think nothing of killing and eating pigs
cows chickens fish and all the others
and it's not because those animals are
less intelligent or have less value or
feel pain less or don't have a heart or
don't have a brain or something like
that it is simply because they're the
ones we've chosen and they're
that we like the taste of and so we're
so hypocritical you know there's a
couple of good quotes that came to mind
because the heart beats under a covering
of feathers scales wings off it is for
that reason to be of no accounts just
because they look a little different on
the outside they're still our brothers
and sisters covered in feather scales
wings or fur and Gandhi said you can
judge the nation's moral progress by the
way that they treat their animals every
single nation has slaughterhouses every
single nation breeds animals into
existence against our will like these
mothers in the dairy industry for
example they're restrained by a human
who will shove their arm into her anus
and then inject her with bull semen and
you just put a human in that situation
and that is rape and we do the same to
animals and it is the dairy industry
business as usual another day on a dairy
farm they are not willing participants
in that there have a pregnancy forced on
them after nine months their babies are
born and they're taken away from them
straight away kidnapping the baby boys
are sent to the slaughterhouse because
they don't produce milk they're
slaughtered infanticide and then the
mothers I used as milk slaves hooked up
to milking machines every day really
impregnated every year for five to seven
years and after that time then they're
so severely exploited that they drop
called a Down cow that caste sent to the
same slaughterhouse is her baby and gets
stabbed in the throat and killed as well
that's just so we can have a glass of
milk when we have soy rice almond
coconut
hazelnut milk hemp milk all of the same
supermarket you can make oat milk from
blending a cup of oats with four cups of
water in a blender and straining it and
you've got oat milk like that we don't
need to do any of this France to these
animals so when we have these facilities
all over the world in every nation and
and we are creating our societies from
the backs of animals on the backs of
this enslavement and killing there's not
a single more nation on the planet and
we've got a long way to go before we get
there because it's you know vegans are a
very small percentage of people on this
planet but that's the path the path is
right there which we've gotten it so
well that we've got all your favorite
foods we've got all the healthy from
we've got millions of recipes out there
we've got everything someone needs to go
vegan just they're just waiting for
someone to start walking and that's the
path out of ant we could end animal
cruelty forever we could fix the
environment in such a massive way like
this path if everyone just did what
vegans were already doing like billions
billions of Earthlings would not be
suffering and being murdered every
single year I don't know how you feel
about this but I think that holds a huge
energy when we're consuming the products
of violence and torture is it any wonder
that we are feeling stressed and anxious
and depressed and you know struggling
with our emotions and drugging ourselves
with food and with drugs and with
television and things like that I think
as well when we have all this violence
in the air when the slaughterhouse is
just around the corner from here that
that's a vibration man that's happening
energy is a real thing and I think that
this world is so far from its proper
potential and and violence breeds
violence the slaughterhouse workers are
being trained to kill good people I'm
not saying they're bad people that's
just the job they're doing in a world
that's normalized violence against
certain species and the studies show
that surrounding areas of
slaughterhouses have higher rates of
violent crime suicide drug abuse and
that spreads out as well man so it's not
just that we're killing animals it's
that way it's bit breeding more violence
in our societies and it's got a ripple
effect that is you know something we'll
probably be writing many many books
about in future years yeah that was
that's very eloquently said and I'm
completely on board with it with
everything that that you just explained
I think there's a lot of people who can
wrap their heads around the ethical
dilemma of eating animals I think it
becomes a little bit more difficult for
people to understand veganism versus
vegetarianism because we're not educated
adequately on the the evils of the dairy
industry which you just explained I mean
there's
so much that goes into that I mean I
think there's a lot of people think I'm
vegetarian but you know I'm gonna I'm
gonna have milk and cheese they're not
killing the animal and that just below
is a lack of understanding of what
actually that industry entails and I
think it's a further leap for people to
wrap their heads around the sort of
karmic spiritual toll of ingesting these
products and having these industries in
our environment I certainly am on your
page when it comes to that I think
everything is energy and I think when
you're when your surroundings when your
environment is carrying that vibration
that that that is impacting you and when
you're ingesting these animals who were
tortured and having these you know
hormonal surges at the moment of death
you're taking that into your body and
for many it's a leap to say well you
know that who cares it's just it's it's
macronutrients and you know science
isn't going to explain anything beyond
that but I think that there's there is a
there is a spiritual toll that you pay
by participating in that system
ingesting these products into your body
and how that manifests in your spiritual
emotional in your spiritual emotional
self and how you carry yourself in the
world and I can tell you from my own
experience and I know this is your
experience as well when you remove those
things from your plates and when you
extract yourself from that environment
there is a purification that takes place
that that made me feel like a more
integrated individual who is living not
just more in accordance with with my own
personal values but exempting yourself
from that I think has you know has an
impact on you that that that defies what
we can currently explain scientifically
absolutely I think it's quite obvious
because there is a serious connection
that is being severed every time you
purchase meat dairy and eggs like I said
you would never contribute to so much
violence you you're not just paying for
a product and nearly wrapped a package
on the supermarket shelf you're paying
for everything that happened to that
animal
along the way in order to get there and
you would most people would never be
okay with even a tenth of the violence
and the suffering that is caused works
we're all inherently compassionate right
we've made this bargain where we've
convinced ourselves that this is okay
and we're willing to participate in this
system because we've been led to believe
that it's necessary exactly and so we
compartmentalize these things we put it
in our unconscious mind so that when we
are reaching for that milk or that you
know the ground beef or whatever it is
it doesn't even occur to it deliberately
until it really made so that you look at
the cotton and you see this happy cow
and you think yeah I feel good about
this no big deal and I need a fur
calcium so what am I gonna do and I
think you're totally right I feel
totally different being vegan now you
know I went vegetarian like I said for
that experiment and I I spent about a
year as a vegetarian I was still
struggling with my eating disorder at
the time I ended up doing a 10-day
meditation as recommended by the man who
said eating your back yeah that my
Eskimo is right your spiritual guru yeah
and you know during this 10-day
meditation which is of a Pastner course
so you meditate ten hours a day for ten
days in silence I had the idea to do a
year-long vow of silence to raise
awareness for animals I thought that
would be just something that would draw
attention to to their plight you know I
write I Drive around Australia I write a
blog about my experience hopefully
people want to pay attention to what I'm
doing and then I'll plant some seeds
along the way and I knew if I was going
to do that you know I don't leave been
vegetarian for a few months at that
point that I needed to learn a lot more
and I started asking finding the answers
to the questions like you said but God
said this and but what about protein
what about free-range and what about if
we humanely kill them and all these kind
of things and during that time is when I
realize ah being vegetarian is not
enough all animal use is a form of
exploitation exploitation is a form of
abuse and all abuse is immoral so I
guess that means it's not just about me
it's also about dairy eggs leather it's
about products that contain animal
I've been tested on animals we test our
shampoo on animals for example all these
things and I thought ok but always
thought vegans were extreme but actually
looking at it it looks quite peaceful
and very kind and just simply the right
thing to do the way I was living my life
seems extreme now extremely violent
cruel and unnecessary the main thing is
it's unnecessary to live like that and I
started learning more about veganism and
when I went vegan I still wasn't an
animal lover you know I went vegan the
day I started my vow of silence same day
I was also the same day that I said from
this day on I'm never bending and
purging again and I haven't once since
which was nearly five years ago now I
was a really cool day and it took time
for me to reconnect to these animals
that I'd severed this connection to I
was going to sanctuaries I met a dairy
cow who was you know baby cow who was
sent to the dairy industry who we
rescued and I spent six weeks with with
him his name's Rupert and I learned
about this cow and and what they're like
and how they feel and express themselves
and you know kind of tell you what they
want and things like that and it took
time though for me to become an animal
lover but now like this change is
happening me is so huge because I see
animals now and I feel like they're just
family and they've got their own
families and I watch them I think wow
what are you doing right now like where
are you going and you're just playing or
you you got a plan to that you know when
that birds a fly and I just think you
just enjoying yourself with a lot of
time they are and ants they're always so
busy and I'm just checking out life now
in a way that I never did before and you
know I'm appreciating all these all
these creatures everywhere in a way I
never did before I think that's where
the Dominion comes in you look in our
form it's like man does anybody like
what can we do does anybody need help
and I think that's where the calling to
not just be vegan but spread this vital
message comes in I'm always super
interested in the defining moments in
people's lives that that transform how
they live and kind of forge a new path
for how they you know how they reinvent
themselves and you know when I look at
your life it seems like there's two
there's the there's the entry point of
the S
guru right and there is this vApp asana
meditation retreat silent meditation
retreat that you that you went on which
has been kind of a recurring theme on
this podcast I've had several people
whose lives have been altered in amazing
ways by virtue of hitting timeout and
going on one of these retreats it's
definitely something you know I'm keen
to do in the near future maybe most
notably you've all know a Harare who
like has written these you know
earth-shattering books and he's very
clear that he would never have been able
to have the big ideas that he conveys in
his writing and his speaking without
without doing he does an annual 60-day
for possible oh what a broad that's
where he really like these ideas occur
to him well yeah that then influenced
the world right and I see in your own
case a similar example so was it
explained to me the impact of that
retreat and that experience of
meditation and how that that really led
to I mean it's it seems to me that this
is the experience that really kind of
forged the clarity to live this new life
but Posner gave me the technique for
sure it it basically you go to this
place you don't talk to anyone you don't
look at anyone you get guided for 10
days 10 hours a day into this meditation
technique called for Pastner which they
describe as the technique that the
Buddha discovered to fully liberate
yourself from suffering and apparently
that's pretty much all he taught but it
was always surrounded it all surrounded
this technique the technique is two
equal parts it is observation of your
physical sensations and equanimity which
means balance of the mind so you're
basically just accepting the moment in
whatever way presents itself the reason
why it helps is because the reason why
they use the physical sensation level is
Buddha's discovery was that that is
where you start to create habit patterns
you have a physical sensation and you
react in a certain way where
with craving or with aversion so you
have a good sensation you got are good
you react crave crave crave but as
nature goes all sensations and
everything is impermanent as that
sensation starts to leave you crave more
or no it's going where's it going and
then you start to suffer because of that
or it's say the sensation is pain
immediately you address of the pain you
don't want it to be there you resist no
I don't want this pain when will this
pain go I hope it's Pangos soon and
eventually it goes nature was going to
take care of it anyway and what we do
instead of just observing and accepting
the moment as it is weak link we resist
that causes our suffering we get into
these this addiction of clinging and
craving and we're suffering almost all
the time and a lot of it is in our head
we paint so many pictures in our head of
what we want our life to be or what our
life was and we wish it was or things
that happened and we react to these
pictures in our head as if they're real
and that causes suffering too so
basically the technique is about sitting
there and letting the the flow of nature
the flow of these sensations come
through your body you scan your body
from top to bottom and you just observe
what's happening and you fully accept
the worst pain if you can and you fully
let go of the the nicest flow of
sensation and you become more solid so
the good feelings don't throw you up and
the bad feelings don't throw you down
you just become consistently accepting
and it brings a strong peace that is a
really beautiful thing and you know it
doesn't mean you're perfect straight
away you know into ten days you like yo
I'm in Leiden right here we go but what
happens is that if you let's say for
example a sensation that you react to
you know you react in a way that brings
anger in your mind instead of it being
an 8 out of 10 anger that you are in for
six hours or even two days it's a seven
out of 10 and it's a six and it's a five
and you don't roll in it for two days
rolling it for one day and then twelve
hours and then eight hours and and
that's how you come out of it that's how
you know that you're progressing on the
path so when I learned this technique I
was so
so lucky to learn this man because I had
never given up you know with my cancer
with my drug-induced psychosis with any
of these things but when it came to my
eating disorder I was like okay I don't
know how to get out of this I have tried
and tried and tried and I just I've read
books I I don't know what else to do
this gave me the technique to come out
of it I didn't come out of it
straightaway and I actually I was so
lucky I found this other book I was
reading I was looking for another book
for a friend called the power by Rhonda
Byrne which is about how to live a
positive great grateful life which is a
really great book but I in because I
couldn't find it there I found this
other book called and emotional eating
by dr. Jennifer Tate's and basically
when I read this like I read the back
and I read the back page I was like oh
my god this is the book this is gonna
get me out of here
I just knew it and I read it and it was
like she'd adopted the parsing the
technique
specifically to emotional eating Wow oh
man it was it was so serendipitous and
as I read it I just knew this is it this
is it and I started coming out of it to
the point where you know I was still
struggling and I'd be vegan for two
weeks straight up vegan you know eating
only plant-based and then I'd have a
binge on ice cream and I hate myself for
him like damn I didn't want to be doing
this I know the dairy industry now I
want to be putting this negative food
into my body anymore and I it was the
eating disorder that was kind of getting
the better of me that's why I made a
date I said from this day on January 1st
I'm vegan no more slip-ups and I'm not
binging and purging anymore a few days
into my vow of silence I did binge I had
a giant peanut butter and a liter of ice
cream and I hate pretty much I had a
whole lot of ice cream and almost a
giant peanut butter man and I'm sitting
there just feeling sorry for myself just
thinking man this could come back up
real easily
three days after I'd made these vows to
myself and I said nah you made a vow and
you are sticking to it and I just sat
there so uncomfortable and then the next
time I binge to a week or two later I
got I got a lot of the way and I say I
got 90 percent in and I was like hang on
a minute I did not want to feel like I
felt the other day and I stopped a
little bit sooner and
but soon I started surfing these urges
to over consume food and and that's how
I came out of it just using to have a
passing technique it's really important
and refreshing to hear that because
you're somebody who I think a lot of
people look at as like super hardcore
and like you're like hey man draw the
line in the sand and that's it and to
hear that you struggled and that you
slipped up and you know it's a it's a
process for everybody I think is is
important you know is important for
people to understand about how you
evolved into this but it is amazing so
you so so you have this Vipassana
retreat and then how long after that do
you make this so it's around then that
you decide to go totally vegan you have
a couple slip-ups or whatever like what
is the timeline in terms of saying
you're gonna do this year of silence
well first let me just a grade of
something you said I think is a really
important point to touch on it is a
process you don't just unravel decades
of conditioning in a in an overnight you
know you don't just change your whole
life overnight I mean some people do and
they go vegan and like bomb I threw out
all my meat and dairy and eggs and I'm
done some people go vegetarian for a
year some people do it for three months
some people start eating vegan for
breakfast vegan for lunch then vegan for
dinner some people do meatless Mondays
and they get through this way but I
think the point is just start somewhere
maybe all you do today is okay from now
I'm not going to buy a cow's milk I'm
going to buy soy milk and that's your
thing there's really not that people a
lot of people say don't promote baby
steps baby steps of her babies man
there's not that many steps to go vegan
it's actually quite easy if it was hard
you wouldn't see so many people doing it
all around the world and just a cat you
know average people like you don't have
to be highly intelligent you don't have
to be have strong willpower like it's
nothing like that it's just okay there's
a few things I need to do here you need
to change my milk eat beans instead of
meat or tofu or vegan meat and you know
okay well I guess I have smoothies for
breakfast like you just figure it out
doesn't all happen overnight people are
busy and don't let that discourage you
oh I could never go all the way vegan
you probably can you probably find out
way easier than you expect you'll find
it infinitely more rewarding
and you would expect as well and that's
the experience of I've spoke to
thousands of Vegas now you ask any of
them what's the best thing you ever did
they're almost all tell you when I went
vegan and there's so many reasons for
that
but whatever take a step start often one
step has momentum that follows with the
next and the next and just get there as
fast as you can you know yeah veganism
is the goal and we should all do it
should be the moral baseline of our
society we should simply just not be
killing if we don't need to and we
should simply not be taking what it's
not ours in the first place
but that doesn't you know of course just
do it as practically as you can I also
don't want people to try it overnight
go I tried it I couldn't do it that
wasn't for me and then just never tried
it again I think it's not for them I do
it was sustainable for you okay so and
that's right dude that's what a lot of
people did most vegans were vegan now
did not go vegan overnight they were
start yeah no human the human vehicle
doesn't work that way but I think
there's a lot of people that think that
that is the way it is or the people that
are outspoken about it did make that
switch and they did it perfectly and
they did it overnight and and people are
intimidated because they feel like they
can't live up to that standard and so
even if they take a shot at it they have
one slip-up and they're out I'm good at
power we've got n courage people man and
we've got a you know people sleep up
don't be like okay well you're out of
the club is like okay so what did you
sleep up on how can I help you with that
well how can you help youself with that
so that next time you want prepared and
that sleep up doesn't happen let's learn
from this mistake and next time
hopefully doesn't happen and sometimes
those explanations are practical like I
just didn't you know organize my day so
that I could get to the market in time
or whatever and I went home and I didn't
clean out my cupboard and there the
convenient choice was the unhealthy
choice or sometimes it's a more complex
answer that has to do with the emotional
triggers that lead you to make those
choices which is you know that you had
to go through everything that you had to
go through with your experience of
emotional eating in order to have enough
self-awareness to rectify those behavior
patterns but I think a lot of people are
so disconnected from themselves that
even the idea that there are
eating seems Anathem I like what do you
mean I'm emotionally yeah like they're
doing it but just getting them to the
place of making that connection is a
challenge in the first place
forget about going vegan totally you
know what I mean totally and I was
dedicated to fixing that problem and it
took me a long time to come out of it so
yeah we're all in our own path and let's
just support each other and help you
know help move people in that direction
plant seeds where possible and you know
just help out where you can and it's not
our job to make anyone go vegan we just
gotta give them all the information we
can make it as convenient as easy as
possible and people will do what they
kind of do what's great about your story
and and and forgive me but kinda
hilarious is that you embark on this
year of silence when you're like vegan
five minutes right not even five minutes
one second no this must've been vegan
for like ten years he's so intense and
hardcore about it like you like mouths
fresh fresh vegan meat it's kind of
funny I know man I was very passionate
like as soon as I figured it out soon as
I kind of realized what was happening
and how needless all this violence was I
was like whoa man do I really know this
massive secret that most people don't
seem to know I could just felt like no I
must be wrong there must be something
I'm missing we must have to do it for
some reason and when I realized actually
no just not a lot of people get this I
thought whoa I felt so grateful that I'd
just gone down the path I hadn't come
into the knowledge that I hadn't been
interested enough in health to learn
that it's perfectly healthy and all
these kind of things are so grateful man
and and yeah when you when you learn
about such an atrocity yeah you just
feel compelled to do whatever you can
and you know I'm not a doctor and I am
NOT a documentary maker and there's a
lot of great ways to help but for me I'd
had a pretty I've gone through some
pretty intense things in my life and you
know take any long vows silence it was
interesting to me and to a lot of people
I know they would have thought it was a
lot more wild than what I did I thought
I oh that would be sweet I'll do that
there's a lot of people like what are
you gonna do what I mean it is pretty
intense yeah come on dance like walk me
through just the practical aspects of
like how you live when you make this
decision yeah
for a year Wow were you physical were
you a physical trainer at that tie took
the year off to travel around Australia
I wanted to make the journey more
interesting and I knew all my mates were
plotting ways to get me to slip up so I
got to be away from home you guys and
I'm just gonna go on a little journey
around Australia setting traps four
years earlier man they would have to
like fake emergencies I don't know they
would have figured it out they're crafty
Bunch
huh so I yeah I decided to get a van
travel around Australia and write a blog
about my experience and basically coming
into contact with people was for the
first while I was just writing
everything down every word which was
extremely frustrating on both sides and
it made me want to do a lot more
listenings you carry around like a
little chalkboard thing I went to court
I went through a lot of notebooks I went
through a lot and how many years ago was
this that was 2014 January 1st of May or
not really so I did that you know I
started just sort of I went vegan that
day so I didn't really know what was
going on I volunteered at a sanctuary so
I could make these animals I was
fighting for these animals doing this
thing for these animals I'd never even
met them I'd never met a cow never met a
chicken or a pig so I go to a sanctuary
that's when the rescued babi calf came
in Rupert spent six weeks with him
coolest thing happen man after spending
six weeks of like giving milk you know
this milk to this cow and I'm really
bonding with this little guy such a
beautiful gentle animal like so so sweet
I I was chilling in the barn I had to
say goodbye obviously I couldn't speak
because I've been by that point I think
it had been probably like two or three
months he'd never heard me speak
obviously as well and so I just thought
it to him like I'm gonna use some
telepathy here's all I got we've got
read either so I just told that 50 to
him over by the side of the barn I'm
like Rupert it's been such a pleasure
getting to know you and taking care of
you you know I'm so sorry for what's
happening to you and your family but
we're working on it and we're doing
everything we can I'll see you one day
in the future and I'll come give you a
visit and he walked over to me and every
day because I was giving him the milk
what they do when they want milk they
head but their mums odda to let them
know
so he always our whole relationship
almost was just him head-butting me and
like slobbering on my pants and sucking
on my pants trying to get milk you know
right and yeah and so he comes over to
me I'm like ah here we go I just put
these pants on man he's gonna mess my
pants off he's gonna head-butted me that
was that was how he treated me every day
and this one time after I said that
thing to me in my mind he comes over and
he does something to me that he'd never
done and he just nozzles his head on my
leg I rubbed his head into my leg and
I'm just looking down short of the floor
like oh my god what is this behavior and
I bend down and usually trying to Pat
him he just like kind of just drive
himself into me who knock me over and
I'm just patting him on the head looking
at him he's looking at me I'm like man
we're having a moment here and it was so
weird I started tripping I'm like holy
I might telepathic or something did
he hear me
you know what's going on and it started
making me question well how much do
these animals know you know what can
what are they capable of and I'm not
saying that he heard me he heard me now
I'm not saying that he heard me but you
know imagine if like they pick up on
things they pick up on vibes they're
they're insuring in different ways and
we are and you know I'm not saying you
heard me but it was just such
fascinating behavior to exhibit after
that experience for the first time on
the day that I'm leaving was really
weird well we want to believe that
they're dumb animals because it makes it
easier for us to make the choice to eat
them the truth is very different and you
mentioned specie is ax murderer and it's
such a weird thing specie ism you know
we make these almost random decisions
about animals that we decide to love and
protect and covet versus animals that we
wrap our heads heads around eating
without any ethical or moral dilemma
you know pigs are the easiest example
because I mean by all accounts they're
smarter than dogs they're more intuitive
they have interior lives on a level that
we don't like to admit to our lock
buzzes like a human toddlers
a big difference between human animals
and other species of animals is we were
blessed with a complicated voice box and
that gave us the ability to create a
sophisticated language and therefore a
sophisticated society but you put a
human out in the jungle and you know you
start getting it go on there then I'm
just going to be starting popping out
iPhones like that is a process that
takes so much communication which is
what we had going for us for the most
part they're going to act like any other
animal
you know fend for themselves and take
care of their family and dude that's
yeah we're we're blessed in that way and
that's why we've done what we've done
but fundamentally we're just animals as
well and there and we're intelligent and
they're intelligent and we shouldn't
judge you know Einstein said if you
judge a fish by his or her ability to
climb a tree though for their whole life
believe that they are stupid but they
are no interest in doing that and you
know there's incredible tales of just
just facts about animals that you think
wow I didn't know they could do that but
um you know they doing it every day and
we just need a it's just just it's just
the Golden Rule it's just about treating
others the way that you'd want to be
treated and disrespecting them and you
would want to be hurt and you wouldn't
want to be exploited you wouldn't want
to be any of these things that we do to
them let's just do that basic thing and
show them the same courtesy especially
when it's so easy for us to do so from a
philosophical and ethical perspective I
think that it's almost beyond debate
what the moral landscape looks like in
terms of you know how we think about
eating animals but sentience kind of
sits on a spectrum on the highest level
you have human sentience or dolphin
sentience and then you know as you go
down the scale sentience sort of I'm
interested in your definition of
sentience and and how that plays into
how you think about these things but
when you get down to you know lower more
base forms of animal life like mollusks
yeah you know how do we you know how do
we think about and act upon that insects
and the like and I and I raised this
because from
a purely devil's advocate perspective
these are arguments that are brought up
on the fringes of what we I think can
generally agree upon ethically as an
argument against adopting this lifestyle
well what's wrong with eating mollusks
because they're less complex than plants
and did you not know that that plants
actually have very complicated ways of
communicating with each other and these
neural pathways and blah blah blah so
you know are you perpetrating a greater
harm by eating a plant than eating
eating a you know eating scallops for
example that's a good question I think
you know when it comes to oysters and
mussels and things like that just from
what I understand they have clusters of
nerves that can act in a unique type of
central nervous system I'll just are on
the side of caution ethically and
health-wise I don't think they're
healthy food to eat either but yeah I
guess there's a little bit more airing
on the side of caution because it's a
little bit more up for debate and I can
try the understand why people might say
that is a great area of me personally I
just think well maybe they are sent
sending in their own little way and
maybe just causes them some harm and if
so I just won't bother I don't need to
eat them so I won't eat them when it
comes to plants I think the biggest
difference is that they aren't sentient
beings they don't have a heart they
don't have a brain there's no one there
there's no individual observing life and
experiencing sensations in a way that we
do like pain because to have the feeling
of pain you need to have a central
nervous system but even if one day we
found out we were wrong actually plants
are sentient beings then hopefully we
can find a way out of the mess we are in
but being a human means you are going to
have to cause some harm and veganism
isn't about zero harm it is ideally that
would be great but it's impossible so
veganism by definition is to strive
because the least amount of harm
practically possible and if we want to
cause less harm to plants which we
should like why not
then we should still be eating only a
plant-based diet because we would be
feeding animals six to twelve or some
say six to 15 times more plants
to fatten these animals up before we
also kill the animals so we give them
this huge amount of food we get back
this tiny little bit of food and it's
totally an inefficient way so it'd be
better just to eat directly yeah I think
it's important they like have these
conversations about these fringe issues
if for no other reason than it's an
interesting academic thought experiment
but the reason I brought it up another
reason I brought it up is I think that
it gets thrown out as an argument
against adopting this lifestyle almost
as a Hail Mary distraction because
regardless of how we play out that
experiment in our minds or through
discourse what is the impact of that in
terms of the the moral landscape with
respect to eating cows and pigs right
mmm I think there's a huge difference
men I think we can see that if you chop
a leaf off a tree you know or pull an
orange off a tree you don't even have to
kill a plant in order to eat from the
plant you take the orange and more seeds
are spread and more plants are grown
whereas you rip a leg off a dog or a
four lamb and there is not gonna be more
dogs growing you're gonna see a dog in
extreme pain and who's probably going to
die so I think there's a big difference
between mowing the grass and chopping
the head off fifty thousand animals you
know and and I think most people know
that and I think you're right people
just they just say it's just another
thing that they say like now we need
meat for protein that plants feel pain
and yeah it's just it's just another
another common objection that has has no
weight yeah it's important to talk about
this idea of aspiring to do less harm
and it's not about perfection and I
think a big impediment to people
embracing this lifestyle is this sense
that that vegans walk around thinking
they're morally superior or that they're
on some kind of pedestal you
condescending to other people and
judging them people don't want to feel
that way they don't want to be talked to
you that way
they don't want to be in relationship
with people in that manner and I think
in order to be an effective communicator
an advocate it does go back to
compassion and I think in order to
really objectively assess the extent to
which we are perpetrating harm or less
arm it's it's even more complicated than
just ok I'm removing animal products
like if you're you're like ok I'm vegan
that's great
but if you're buying all your clothes
from some fast faction you know fast
fast fashion factory that's turning out
you know toxic waste into the rivers
around Malaysia or you know somewhere in
the Philippines that's causing that's
depopulating the the the fish population
in that waterway you're actually causing
more harm than if you bought your
clothes from Goodwill and ate a steak
once a month so it I think it's more
that's a really good point there's a lot
you know there's downstream impacts to
all the consumer choices that we're
making not just with our food but with
other products and and I say that
because none of us is immune from
causing harm I live in a modern world I
fly in airplanes yeah me too you know I
have an iPhone I don't know where all
those precious minerals come from and
the harm that's caused as a result of
mining those so let's get off our our
pet our moral pedestal all right
absolutely and try to embrace people
where they are in this communal spirit
of how can we all just do better and and
love each other more deeply totally what
do you know this is what I know let's
help each other be better people I think
one one thing about veganism is that
first of all we eat three times a day
and most people are eating animal
products three times a day or at least
every day whereas when we buy clothes or
an iPhone it's more like I mean
personally I buy clothes like every not
even every six months maybe every year
same with a phone probably not even that
often
so I think that in terms of and also
like when you can choose ethical
clothing of course we should that should
be a given that that's what we choose
when an ethical iPhone comes out I'm
sure vegans will be the first to jump on
it and and it doesn't mean oh but you
don't jump on it now Sookie I know and
that's true like we I guess we all draw
a line somewhere and I'm guilty of that
too which is why I really try not to
judge anybody else on the choices they
make and just try to encourage that you
know the worst thing I think that we're
contributing to as far as I can tell the
same the same pretty obvious is choosing
to consume animal products especially
for food because we eat so often and
there's so much it's so much violence
that is direct its direct you know it's
not we buy from this factory and then
there's pollution that goes into war
waits its
I'm paying for you to kill for me which
also has kind of kind of yeah the
consequence of I'm just condoning
violence in a very open way in our
society yeah but I agreement no one's
perfect and we should always striving to
do better and those who can really
should and I hope it becomes easy for us
to to choose more ethical clothing just
like it's become more easier for us to
choose soy milk instead of cow's milk
yeah it's getting easier you know a lot
of those a lot of those lines those
brands are expensive yeah but the idea
is like hey you don't need 10 white
t-shirts how about just one that will
last a long time that wasn't created
with the toxic dyes and actually
supports the indigenous community that
created it you know all of those things
we're seeing more and more of that and I
find great hope and inspiration and
optimism in in you know people of your
generation and even the generation
beneath you who care about these things
more deeply than than people my age for
the most part and and are very
intentional about ensuring that the
dollar they spend is contributing to the
world that they want to live in totally
yeah it's great that people realize we
can vote without all of these days
yeah it's it's hard not to know about
you know a lot of the big issues because
it's yeah especially veganism the bigger
movement it's being publicized so
regularly in the media and online that
it's kind of hard to hide from right now
and it continues to grow despite a lot
of vested interests that are trying to
dismantle it and able eyes that they
must be scared man I mean it's a great
example that they are trying to stop
plant-based milks from being called milk
mm-hmm you know no you can't call it
milk and it's like well you don't have a
problem with peanut butter so why the
problem with almond milk but as well
then you know we'll just find ways
around that like Oly which make oat milk
they have this great advertising
campaign right now that says oddly it's
like milk but made for humans so it's
brilliant yeah there are a lot of
lawsuits out there attacking plant-based
food companies for coming anywhere near
using that verbiage hmm
and I know a little bit more about this
than probably the average person because
Julie my wife is trying to launch this
plant-based cheese line and originally
she wanted to call it this Jesus nuts
because that's the name of her book and
I was like babe I don't think it's a
good idea you use that what you're
opening yourself up to attack by using
that word and we did some research and
there's a crazy amount of lawsuits that
go on just in the cheese realm alone
like you can't even use the word
gorgonzola or Parmesan or mozzarella
confusing a well-intentioned customer as
to the origin like the ingredients of
the product and basically what I see and
that is and you saw it with Hampton
Creek just and you know the mayonnaise
Wars and all these things are going on
and it's it's really a desperate attempt
to try to stave off this tidal wave
that's coming no matter what and
desperate is the word you would be
desperate because we're making food that
tastes the same looks the same smells
the same no one died better for the
environment and would be a competitive
price they must be free
and actually just about that you just
reminded me of you know we're not
allowed to use these specific words but
I really appreciate that sometimes it
goes the other way and that the egg
industry isn't legally allowed to use
any word that classifies eggs as healthy
or any word that resembles the word
healthy so sometimes it also grant you I
didn't know yeah I watched I don't know
dr. Greger video I'm pretty sure ah Wow
yes well interesting times indeed like
I'm still I'm still back it inside of my
bass line you're like silence like just
do you meet somebody who went a whole
year without saying a word eloquent and
well-spoken like all the more
challenging I've helped me I think
so I'm just compensating now it's pretty
much shut up since to be honest um cuz
you know like everyone makes that joke I
had you know someone's good how do you
know when someone's big and don't worry
I'll tell you I went vegan I didn't tell
anybody Beverly for a year only vegan
that ever done burbly but but perhaps
you also in a way that was even more I
mean you went there I was cool a dude
who was five minutes vegan and nobody
knew who you were - one year later at
the culmination of that one year period
going on on television that just you
know created like a you know a huge
viral moment on yeah yeah I'm really
glad that happened so yeah I spend that
year in silence I traveled around I you
know I attended sanctuaries to volunteer
and I also went into a lot of factory
farms under the cover of night to see if
it really was as bad as you know I've
been told in my country in Australia and
what I realized immediately after going
through dozens of them is that it is at
least as bad as what I thought it was
and it is at with numbers that are just
beyond comprehension
so that really fueled my fire and yeah I
was writing everything down then when I
realized that I could use body language
and I thought basically was a year-long
game of charades I also moved my math so
the people could lip-read without
speaking to make things easier that's
change the whole galaxy that yes it's
almost like cheating
heyo as well I think it was the hack is
the hype I was still voiceless which was
my vow we're sending a lot of emails on
yeah I was writing a lot of a most the
show I did a lot of I did a lot of
FaceTime with people like trying to make
it work
my brother was really good at that
anyway so I ended up also my van broke
down halfway into my journey and it was
really cool man I was just you know you
can't go a year without without using
words unless you have a van
totally yeah she got a fan and you also
can't wear shoes very often yes anyway
Locke's optional yeah exactly
my van broke down I ended up here
talking like 2,000 kilometres up to
Darwin and I flew over to Bali because I
wanted to get some tattoos I got my arm
covered my arms covered in animal rights
tattoos they also they kind of tell the
whole story really there's some quotes
assumptions you had no tattoos before
this I had tattoos just not on my arms
and yeah I just wanted them to tell a
story so when people say what are your
arm tattoos about they can sit down they
can see the picture of the line and it
says Lions kill for need humans kill for
greed or the picture of the cow getting
slaughtered by the slaughterhouse worker
and says wash which begins whenever
someone looks at a slaughterhouse and
thinks they're only animals and there's
a whole bunch of them like that there's
a photo of me in a mask off what we've
just done that chicken rescue rescue
about 200 little chicks and it says we
are fighting into every cages empty not
into every cage is comfortable and you
know there's a bunch more like that so
hardcore yeah it's cool good so fun I
was nice to you know you see so much of
the cruelty and violence on Facebook and
for a long time I was just taking
footage and videos and photos of it and
then when we started doing rescues and
you hear all those little birds chirpin
in the back of the car as you're driving
away and you just it's such a good
feeling it's small like you left so many
behind but to them to those so those
individuals it means everything and yeah
I ended up I hitchhiked to down I went
and got those tattoos I came back and I
saw cooed 5000 kilometers about three
while from Darwin through the outback to
Sydney
Wow yeah long way Oh as long as long a
lying coast though not alone cut
straight through the straight through
the middle for people that don't know
Darwin is the northern tip yeah of
Australia yeah so I had to come down and
then across and it was just long
stretches of straight road with no cars
by myself you know in the middle of
nowhere just I'd have to cycle usually
there's about 100 120 KS maybe easier to
not have to talk though it was the best
I didn't have to do all this charade
game anymore it was such a nice break
flow because bicycles broke down and
you're in some little village right you
gotta like you need some help I do I
want this guy talk on earth everyone
thought you death or something like
cheese but I just I had cars written up
I'm taking yelling violence to raise
awareness for animals I'm promote peace
over violence I just give it to them
like okay this is wanker that's even
weirder this guy you know what was cool
though it spurred the conversation even
though I had to have it non-verbally I
still was getting pretty good at
communicating and every single person
that came into contact with me during
that year they asked why you voiceless
and so meetings always want a
opportunity to talk about this we're
just waiting to slip it into the convo
this gave me an opportunity to bring it
up at any time and just poke yeah this
is why I've done it and you know you can
watch this documentary I had a bunch of
DVDs I was given out at the time and got
saket across Australia is one of most
painful things I've ever done because my
seat was like so far man and if your guy
who sold it to me I'm like you sure
about this seat you know I'm just you
know doing my nonverbals and he said
yeah man it's a good seat I was like all
right I mean the whole way I was
thinking about this guy like if I ever
see you again so much banging my ass is
killing me my legs aren't too bad and I
also just wanted to show you know you
can be healthy feeling strong and do
cool things like that on a plant-based
diet I did it all by myself I get back
to Australia I get an email I'm sorry I
get back to Sydney I get an email from
sunrise the morning TV show and I said
would you like to break your vow silence
on our show we call it on to story and
how did they we on from your blog or I
don't know
getting press around this I had a had a
few news
you know newspaper interviews and I've
done a bunch of interviews for some
online stuff but I don't know how they
got onto it actually maybe someone wrote
in like it was about to end and you know
had a bunch of people following my
journey by then and this is Lyman a Good
Morning America or the ta show yeah it's
the most popular one in Australia it's
called sunrise so anyway at first I was
thinking man no way I just wanted you to
be over you know I'm so sick of it it
was hard you know being voiceless and
just writing a blog nearly every single
day and yeah that whole cycling trip so
but you know initially I was thinking
now I don't want to I was so nervous man
to to speak for the first time on TV and
talk about something so important and
talk on TV for the first time which is
saying I was really not confident in
doing I didn't even want to go on the
radio to promote my thing before I
started I was just not confident in that
way at all at the time were you worried
that your voice might not work totally I
didn't know what was gonna happen he was
people who told me all these stories oh
I knew someone that didn't speak for a
while night they couldn't speak when
they tried to again and I don't know
just a bunch of crap like you had plenty
of time to figure out what it was
exactly that you were gonna say you
would think I would have thought about
it more except by what I did you know I
ended up saying yeah you know I will do
this my vow officially finished January
1st 2015 as the clock struck midnight
but I said well I don't want to go on to
your show that morning because
everyone's gonna be you know it's still
partying and they're not gonna watch
your show that day or maybe they will
but I just figured it would be better to
do it on another day there's already
something special happen in that day and
I waited I said what I'm going to do it
into a 10 day meditation course another
of a Pastner which i think was my third
at that time and I went there starting
January 1st I did my 10-day meditation
and that's where I figured out what I
wanted to say and I spent a lot of that
meditation just really crafting this
this plea basically and then when I when
I went on their show it was the day
after I I did I did say one thing I did
say one thing before that when the clock
struck midnight I was seeing this girl
at the time
and she'd never heard me speak so how
did that work but I was great because I
never was getting myself in trouble I
think I've got worse when I started
talking again
that's hilarious so we you were watching
the fireworks in Sydney and then I gave
her a hug every kiss and just said her
name and then I just was sign again so I
said that but then I shut up again for
the next 10 days I went in my purse and
I came out I sit on this on there you
know at their show and they said all
right drum roll please James what are
you first words going to be and I
non-verbally math to them with my body
language and all that I said I want you
to ask me why and they said oh okay
James why did you do this and I said
thank you for asking it sounded like
this thank you for really yeah totally
man it was it was it's online you can
you can find it yeah I'll put a link in
the show notes up to it yes so I said
thank you for asking the reason I took
this foul silence was to raise awareness
for the voiceless victims of this planet
the animals we all say we love animals
and we're against animal cruelty yeah we
pay people to mutilate and torture and
slaughter them and it's not for any
necessity it's not because we need to
for our health it's because we like the
way they taste so I went voiceless
because they're voiceless I thought but
then I realized they're not actually
voiceless they cry in pain and they
scream in terror and when they do that
they're telling us that they're
suffering but the problem is we're not
listening because they're covered in
feathers or scales or wings off so we
don't take their suffering seriously I
also did this to raise awareness for the
way I've been living my life I'm vegan
which means I don't consume any animal
products and I support any animal
exploitation and I want to show people
through my journey how easy that it is
how healthy that is at delicious the
food is and that if you think violence
is wrong then veganism is right and how
did that go down they just looked real
shocked like huh yeah people eat in
there this is like breakfast TV people
eating that broken and eggs was like
what did this guy just say man I think
it was you know I don't think they
expected in kind of a message like that
and at that time I hadn't really heard
about any sort of strong bigge messages
being on
I'm in Australia at least and you know
before I knew it like that's pretty much
the only question they asked I just sort
of said oh how does it feel to be
talking and I'm like I don't know I
actually expected some dialogue on what
I'd said they didn't they didn't invite
a man in order at all man and I was I
was like I left there a minute later I
was like what the hell just happened we
didn't even talk about I just said
something I hope it was good and you
know I didn't know and then I look at my
phone and it's just blown up with
messages and calls and other radio
stations and all this and I thought okay
cool and you know it was great that it
was short and they didn't answer you
know we didn't talk about it which it's
a short interview just planted a solar
device totally kind of said it said it
everything I could really say in a short
amount of time like that they're like
okay
yeah well anyway next on and what was
the commercial right after you can
imagine so yeah that ironically gave me
a voice but that was seen like it's been
seen like millions of times at times
yeah even in last three months and that
was four years ago knows it's been sent
an extra five million times on my
YouTube and I put it on quite late on my
YouTube but I think it's a it's at least
15 million probably more times it's been
using a lot of really cool documentaries
and different things so yeah it's been
it was a really great man and you know
it was just it was just one it just made
just one guy who is no expert at
anything just having a crack at it and
thankfully it turned out real well I got
on media like I wanted and all I got
hoped and said what I wanted to say it
all came out fairly okay and in a you
know my voice worked which was good and
then yeah then people start asking me to
come around do speeches and I started
talking about my journey and people came
up to me after saying well that was
great I went vegan
I just went vegan I'm like what because
what I just said and they're like yeah I
said oh my god okay this is what I need
to do I'm gonna tell the story now and
since then yeah there's been some other
videos that have got over you know 10
and 12 and 13 million views of me
talking about my journey and and that's
it's been
so that's why I've been doing so much
traveling right so when you were in the
midst of the the year-long valve silence
I mean was there a sense like okay this
is what I'm gonna create a life out of
like notable there's one thing to feel
strongly about about an issue and to do
something significant to be heard on
that and it's a very different thing to
then craft you know basically for lack
of a better word like a career
trajectory out of a message totally well
I tried to go back to being a personal
trainer because I was totally broke by
the end of that year around Australia
and you know I'm helping people who just
need to lose a few kilos or want to put
on a bit of muscle and meanwhile I'm in
about ten different discussions online
about why people should go vegan in my
opinion and why they would agree if they
just had seen what I've seen and things
like that and I just watching my phone
just light up every couple of minutes
and I mean while I'm counting somebody's
repetitions and I just thought you know
I've done this job for a long time and I
love this job and it is very fulfilling
but the victims need people very
dedicated to this they deserve that and
as somebody who has the privilege to
know then I felt like either duty to
really dedicate and just do what I could
so that's when I kind of said okay I
don't know what I'm gonna do and how I'm
gonna make this work but I'm just gonna
say yes to every opportunity and and go
from there and that's pretty much what
I've done since I've there's the only
times I've turned things down is when
I've already got something booked and
you know I've I've sold t-shirts to -
you know get ahead or not get ahead we
kind of just break even really I've
slept on many different couches and you
know I just try to do it as cheaply as
possible since you know just this year I
started a patreon account that's been
really helpful I was hesitant creating
that because I didn't want people to
think I was doing this for you know the
wrong reasons and to make money and I
just didn't want to effect you know
potentially my integrity but at the end
of the day like activists need support
and you know I'm doing all my speeches
for free so there has to be a way in
people more than happy to donate a
couple of dollars a month
there's been has been so much good from
it from traveling and you know speaking
of so many other activists and that's so
many universities and making some viral
content and I'm really I'm really really
grateful to have because it was it was a
leap of faith you know when I gotta
leave early man like I you know it's
been five years like I'm gonna be an
advocate for the voiceless or the
muzzled yeah depending of it and I'm
just gonna make it work somehow yeah the
fact that you have made it work I mean
it's amazing so on a practical level
basically you you've given like 500
speeches in the last couple of years you
don't charge for these speeches but I
would imagine they pay for your airfare
or whatever right yeah and then you have
patreon and then you sell t-shirts and
through those two avenues you're able to
like make it work and live this nomadic
lifestyle where you're just a full-time
voice piece totally and you know I
didn't really know what I was walking
towards as well as like okay am I just
gonna put my life on on hold here and
just just speak about this and do this
thing and you know obviously I was happy
to but there's so many schools I've
learned along the way and there's so
much yeah so much growth that's happened
in me that it's been invaluable for sure
and even just the act of a coward I know
how I'm gonna make this work but I just
really want to make this work and I hope
I can make this work I'm just gonna take
a look the faith and I didn't fall you
know I flew kind of thing and it was
just a really great lesson to just
follow getting into it without knowing
all the answers really any of the
answers just beginning I think it's
super powerful absolutely and I think
you know just man I want every activist
to be able to do it like I know there's
so many activists who would love to work
and and travel as much as me and do as
many speeches and and do everything in
this many they do as much or even more
probably that don't get any support and
don't have a patreon and things like
that
I wish I was you know I wish everyone
was making it work as well because
it's a such an important job and it's
one that there's this kind of mentality
in in the vegan community almost like no
you shouldn't make money off this you
but people it's it's one thing to make
money working to help create a vegan
world and it's another thing to be
making money off the backs of animals
and they're two completely separate in
fact running in the opposite direction
of each other things I think there's a
bit of confusion of that so yeah I think
that's I think it's great if you can
find your passion and you're making a
positive difference in the world and you
can support yourself doing that then of
course that's what you should be doing
yeah and in order to do that though you
have to make some choices about the
lifestyle that you're willing to let
like you got it exactly cut some things
right you know absolutely those yeah
there's a lot of sacrifice that's made
along the way and you just weigh it up
each time so when you're going out
you're giving these talks you're meeting
a lot of people you're doing the
activism work you're at the vigils what
have you how is your perspective evolved
over the last four or five years like
what do you know now that maybe you
didn't even know a year ago a lot I
think it's changed a lot I used to be a
lot more like I think I mentioned
earlier a lot more of a hard-ass about
it you know if you drink dairy this is
your fault and graphic footage kind of
thing like and that he's probably a
taint version of what I would have
actually said although you know I was
just I was just trying to find my fate
and trying to do the cause justice do
the animals justice what I realize now
is that anger isn't necessarily you know
then I want you to be angry they just
want you to be effective all right
that's more important than showing all
your passion about it be pragmatic about
it be effective about it I think I was
much more you know there was certain
philosophies and animal rights you know
animal rights theories that I once
believed that now I don't which were a
lot more like for example frenzy oh nice
right I Peter Singer like super hardcore
or like what more like more like we can
only promote veganism if you do a
single-issue campaign like for example
against dolphin slaughter in Taji and
don't make that a vegan campaign you're
making out you
playing there Dolphins are more
important than other species if you if
you fight against fur and not leather
you're implying that must be much worse
than leather and like there's some merit
to some of these arguments I think but
overall I think certain people will just
they already love dolphins or they're
already against fur and if that's what
gets their foot in the door and then
they can learn the rest of the message
and take more steps then it clearly
works because I've met so many people
that that's worked for I think as well
especially recently I've become a lot
more you know I wouldn't have ever
recommended steps before these people
take steps that's up to them but I would
have always said vegan that's the goal
that's what you need to do do it and
hurry up
well now I'm sort of just like vegan
that's the goal of course it's the goal
but here's an option of the way to get
up the mountain and here's another
option and you could try this way and
whatever way here's all these ways so
just get moving on the pie
I heard Francie Owen give a talk once
and he's like everyone wants that you
know when he's he's addressing this
issue of like the process you know of
taking steps which he's super you know
has a big issue with and he's like
everybody's on their journey they wanna
throughout their journey he's like
your journey he's like oh man and I
think there's a place for that too there
is I mean when you when you look at it
you know the thing that I'm most
sympathetic when it comes to his
perspective is is this idea of humane
meat right like we're in a moment right
now where if you go to Whole Foods or a
natural food market there's a lot of
very crafty marketing around making
people feel better about making this
choice of eating animal products by
injecting it with this sense of goodwill
because these animals are being treated
more more fairly so I want to break down
the reality of that but psychologically
what Franchione would argue and I think
there's merit to this is that by making
people feel better about making this
choice you're actually moving them away
from the direction that you're trying to
drive them which is getting them off of
these products altogether exactly
that's that's true for some people
definitely and that's why it's just you
got a I think it always helps to think
about it in human context is there a
humane way to murder is a humane way to
abuse a child is there a humane slavery
and the answer is obviously no so why do
we think there's a humane way to murder
other species why do why would we use a
word that literally means to show
compassion next to a word that means the
same as murder it just doesn't make any
sense and yeah it's just clever
marketing just to make people feel
better about their choices but there's
no right way to do the wrong thing and a
lesser of two evils is still evil of
course it's better not to torture them
first just like it's better not to
torture slaves but having slaves is
still inherently immoral and needlessly
slaughtering animals for foods and
products it not only we don't need but
there were far better off both without
is also inherently immoral people don't
like to be told that they're immoral for
making this choice and I think that
people are good and I have so much
optimism in people's ability to adapt
with new information and change and to
make better choices and to confront you
know the way that they live because I've
done it myself and I know so many people
who've done it and people do it every
single day and yeah it might be a little
bit uncomfortable to hear at first but I
just want anyone to know who's listening
to this I don't think that anyone who's
eating meat dairy and eggs is a bad
person I think that you most likely just
uninformed or you've got some habits
just like I did and I'm sure that if you
knew you know more about it and about
how to change that you probably would
because that's just what logically a
person with with any a trace of
compassion would do so and I think that
yeah people ate it I see people as
victims you know they're victims of a
society that has basically brainwashed
them and we're trying to just you know a
lot of what my job is is rectifying the
misconceptions that people have and you
know people have all these beliefs that
and
many of them wrong what do you think is
the biggest misconception that people
have that is the most difficult for you
to combat oh the God one for sure is the
hardest one I mean because you're not
really arguing with just just about
about the logic of the situation there
give me initio yeah just in general that
God said this and God said that you know
and I think that that's a really hard
one to combat because you can pick and
choose things in any tax and go I
interpret it this way I interpret it
that way and to suit the way that you
want to live to you know to justify your
choices and people do that all the time
especially on this issue I think that's
definitely the hardest one because one
I'm not that savvy with the the tax of
religions I just try to you know reach
people's heart and just and try to put
people in that situation I think that's
a big one but I also think that it's
just the superiority complex that we
have thinking we are so much better than
every other species and that they don't
matter and we can do what we want
because they're not intelligent or
because this and that like the question
people need to ask is what is so
different between human animals and
non-human animals that if we were to
kill a human we would think it is so bad
and yet if we were to do the same thing
to a nonhuman it is classified as do not
and often a celebration there must be a
very big difference between us and them
for us to justify such cruel behavior
such cruel acts so what is an animal
you'll find if we do ponder that
question is that there's actually no
real difference you know just because
they look different really is what it
comes down to well the bigger battle is
getting people to actually wrestle with
that question to begin with because we
really don't want to ask ourselves that
question and and we've created a system
to to
prevent us from asking ourselves that
question with all these barriers that
disconnect us from the source of where
our food comes from and so what happens
is that produces a lot of cognitive
dissonance he says we rationalize this
choice that we're making we do it
reflexively and unconsciously we we go
out of our way to avoid having to
confront that reality which creates that
dissonance which creates a low vibration
kind of you know weird feeling in all of
us because we're know we know we're
making a choice that's at odds with our
core values which is to be compassionate
and so unraveling that knot becomes
tricky and difficult and you just lay it
out and like you know in in a I wouldn't
say confrontational but in a very plain
spoken manner and I think for a lot of
people it's the first time that they've
ever even thought about it yeah it's not
anyone's fault because this is a system
in the society in which we live Singh I
guess what I'd say is this just added
some encouragement I saw it from
watching the documentary is like a
things or Dominion which is a new one I
still haven't seen Dominion well that's
I don't know why yeah no I do I do want
to I mean I would say Earthlings is a
tough one for paint by our mutual friend
Shawn Monson yeah I mean that's you
mentioned it earlier it's it's it's it's
hard to take out leap of faith and watch
that because it's just truth on a level
that a lot of people are prepared for
yeah and you're gonna feel probably
compelled in one way or another to start
making changes and change feels hard but
I guess what I would say is that you
know like it might take a little bit of
an adjustment but going vegan is so much
easier especially now than you would
think and the food is incredible that
people go vegan and become foodies
because vegan food is amazing
and you feel so good and you're doing
such a good thing for your health and
you're probably going to live longer and
you probably you potentially get off
some medications and you know just
potentially reverse diseases like
there's so much good here if you forget
the animals forget the environment just
you as an individual living this life is
is
the soul transforming and such a
positive thing and you just shine
brighter and feel so good and you become
more aware of what's going on in this
world I'm more aware of who you share
this world with and just gives you a
different glimpse of you know what it
means to be an Earthling and yeah it's
just it's such a cool thing man like
this so much to it when you when you do
you know reconnect your compassion like
we already have compassion iron stein
said we will what they say said I'm
about compassionate hanging around he's
got a couple things he said nothing will
benefit human health and our chances for
survival more than the evolution to a
vegetarian diet which back in the day
was a vegan diet and like when he said
it and he also said we must free
ourselves and our task is to widen our
circle of compassion to embrace all of
nature and all living creatures and yeah
it does free you it frees you in a way
that's sort of hard to explain but I
think every vegan can feel it it's
something that we haven't done as a
species and it's something that's that's
so abundantly clear when you're in an
airplane and you're looking down
particularly if you're flowing at night
and you you're flowing over a city and
you see all the lights and you see what
humans have done to this planet it's so
shocking new to me you know and and when
you lay that on top of this current
landscape in which we're in the midst of
this insane healthcare crisis one out of
every three Americans will die of heart
disease one out of every two Americans
will contract some form of art disease
something like 70 to 80 percent of
Americans are obese or overweight 50% of
Americans will soon be diabetic or
pre-diabetic you know the cancer numbers
are through the roof the childhood
obesity numbers are through the roof
depression is our number one disability
stress and anxiety or epidemics and then
let's look at the environmental
implications of how we live and when we
assess the truth behind animal
agriculture we realize that it's
contributing to the greatest mass P
extinction event in human history is
polluting our water tables its
acidifying our oceans it's emitting more
greenhouse gas emissions than all the
transportation sector combined it uses
more land and it's more resource
intensive than any other industry it
goes on and on and on right it's a very
grim pessimistic picture of the future
of human health and the habitability of
our planet for not just humans but our
animal friends alike and it's easy to
become despondent and pessimistic about
the prospects for the next generation
and the generation to come
you're a very optimistic guy you're very
passionate about what you're talking
about so how do you think about our
chances for the future and and what
things are gonna look like in you know
2030 and 2050 I'm optimistic because I
see change happening every single day
and I think the thing that will probably
sell it that'll probably win it is just
that these food alternatives are going
to be just as accessible and just as
affordable and right next to the ones
that we know are so bad for us and the
planet and the animals so I think that
honestly people will just get on a
plant-based diet before they'll have a
vegan ethic in their heart and I just I
guess I'm optimistic although I don't
know but I hope that and there's enough
people working on this that will make it
happen before we lose you know we lose a
lot and we make some irreparable damage
and we lose a lot of a lot more species
so I don't know what's gonna happen man
I just fight I just fight it like I do
this every day because I know that's my
part to do and I know there's so many
other people out there doing it and
we're such a passionate Bunch you know
where there's and people passionate
about it for different reasons so I just
think there's so many so many passionate
people extremely passionate people
working on it that I hope we can figure
out a way that okay maybe not everyone's
going to you know be aware of what
speciesism is
and say all animals is equal kind of
thing but perhaps I will be aware enough
to choose the beyond me instead of the
you know the corpse the cut out body
part and I think it's no coincidence
that what we're doing right now is bad
for us and bad for the animals and bad
for the planet we kill them they kill us
you know and I think it's also no
coincidence that when we do good for
them we are doing better for ourselves
and better for the planet I think that's
just almost as if nature brings it that
way kind of like that I think nature is
trying to tell us something yeah well I
want to wind this down on an optimistic
note and that is this we all of us want
greater power and agency in our lives
and I think that there is a huge swath
of the human population that feels very
disenfranchised they feel like they lack
power in their own lives they feel like
the world is passing them by and I think
in order to bring some of that sense of
agency back into your life it's
important to understand that all of us
do have power and that each individual
no matter where you sit or find yourself
in society can exercise that power three
times a day with the choices that you
make about the food that you're putting
on your plate it may seem like a small
thing but as you eloquently explained
earlier it is the furthest thing from a
small thing because that decision about
what you're putting on your plate has
downstream ramifications and impact that
are as serious as murder the decision as
to whether this animal is going to live
or die to be on your plate and when you
vote to remove those things from your
plate and to put healthy plant-based
foods onto your plate you are taking a
stand for a better world in the world
that is better for all of us you are
side stepping out of this industry and
it's karmic impact you're taking a stand
for an animal's life or maybe multiple
animals law
lives and that is extremely impactful
and I think if you can think about that
decision that you make every single day
you will realize that that does give you
a sense of agency in your life that
perhaps can provide you with a more
optimistic perspective on how you decide
to live this idea that we can't make a
difference is illusory and I think to
divest ourselves of these decisions and
sit back and wait for Elon Musk to solve
it is to further exempt yourself from
that feeling of agency you know Elon
Musk wants to terraform Mars and that's
an amazing aspiration and perhaps
someday he will do that and that's
incredible but why not terraform our own
planet first let's stop waiting for
somebody else to solve our problems take
ownership of them ourselves and start
making those changes in our own life not
from a perspective of being a martyr but
because it is empowering and because it
will provide you with a sense of purpose
and and and connectedness that maybe you
lack in your own life and I can tell I
can I can speak only from my own
experience but it has been unbelievably
enriching and empowering in my own life
and from sitting across from you hearing
your story and knowing you know just
observing you over the years it's more
than obvious that this has been the case
in your life and I just want everybody
who's listening to this to experience
what you and I have had the good fortune
of experiencing and it's free it's
available to all and it's not as hard or
as tricky as you might think it doesn't
need to be expensive or complicated and
if you can take this leap of faith even
if you just try it for 30 days we'll
gladly refund you your former lifestyle
after that 30 day period if you're not
sold and and take a chance on it I'm
pretty confident that that you will see
in it and feeling it like what James and
I have experienced I am too and I was
extremely well said thank you so much
well awesome to have you here today
it's been an honor and has been talk to
you too and I wish you well in your
journey
and wind in your sails and keep doing
what you're doing my friend thanks
brother thanks for having me on and
thanks for the amazing work you're doing
to getting these messages out there yeah
thanks and a big difference if people
want to jump on your bandwagon probably
the best place for them to go is your
Instagram yeah James Osby yeah Instagram
would be the good place Facebook and my
youtube channel is James and Kali
cool and where can they go to find a
patreon if they want to contribute and
you can just write H on James SB it pops
right up that's that's how huge you are
awesome that and are you doing any
public like where can people if people
want to come out and hear you do your
thing
are they a New York next week yeah I
wasn't gonna go up for a little while oh
okay then I just generally post about my
schedule my Instagram pay yeah so people
we got to figure it out there I don't
dare yeah yeah it's been a pleasure man
thanks so much thank you
PC clients
[Music]
you